les parents n'arrivent pas à comprendre
ce à quoi que non les rangs annonce
inquiète énormément pour les filles
quand elles savent que elle fréquente
des garçons est tout aussi tous
s'inquiètent parce que ils pensent à
leur génération que tout à fait
différente de la nôtre actuelle il est
certain que maintenant avec la mentalité
actuelle des des gamines de 16 ans la
pilule est absolument une chose
merveilleuse et ça c'est peut-être
indispensable enfin je trouve quand même
que si les parents étaient un peu plus
intelligente et d'essayer il est serait
malgré tout de raisonner leurs enfants
je crois que nous on a été d'une époque
où on nous résonnaient et on s'est
toujours raisonné on sait jamais ramené
à 17 ans dix ans à nos parents j'ai des
ennuis fait quelque chose de partir de
juin en 21 langues pour une fille un
garçon et un garçon aussi d'ailleurs
pas de problème la contraception notre
niveau encore c'est pas une question
vraiment qui nous embarrasser alors
quand aux contours pilule nous on n'en
est pas là il nous faudra les pilules
mais nous ça serait pour l'émail la
guerre et ils n'ont pas la même
mentalité que nous ont pillé ses trois
musiciens entre leur génération c'est la
génération actuelle croyez pas qu'ils
aidaient des personnages et des départs
ou des adultes qui pensent qu'un bout et
qui moi je vois mes grands parents sont
plus compréhensifs que mes parents ma
grand mère surtout est très moderne très
jeune et s'inquiètent beaucoup moins que
mes parents est ce que vous iriez avec
une
une jeune femme ou une jeune fille
couchée sous la tente vous promener le
soir vous frottez vos affaires est ce
que vous pourriez le faire
moi je m'en veux pas essayer malgré qu
est la grèce je suis vieux je voudrais
pas essayer noter qu'actuellement ben on
parle beaucoup de moyens qui empêche les
dangers ah ça c'est une autre paire de
manches a oui mais pas suffisamment on
ne sait pas et s'en donne une étrange on
n'a pas approfondi vous comprenez on
aurait été plus jeunes on aura essayé de
savoir davantage de certains que j'avais
20 ans je serai prêt à occuper
sérieusement cette petite histoire non
avec les moyens qui existent est-ce que
vous ne croyez pas que c'est regrettable
in certaine égalité entre l'homme et la
femme
c'est certain ça libérera la femme
seulement jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à quel
point cela libérera repenser libère trop
non plus puisque j'ai pas jusqu'où ça
risque valait 1
l'ensemble des ans des jeunes filles des
jeunes gens ils sont beaucoup plus
précoce que notre temps c'est tout ah
oui on a mis qui disait toujours j'ai
envie de me faire dépuceler parce qu'on
appelle toujours la pucelle dès que je
rentre dans un quelque part on appelle
toujours la puce je pense pas qu'elle
est tellement
c'est un avantage mais enfin je pense
pas que sur le plan santé ce soit très
bon alors ce qu'il ya 16 ans il commence
à se droguer à quel âge on va finir à
mon avis moi personnellement je vous
avoue personnellement je veux pas
d'enfant mais je ne prendrai pas la
pilule
c'était pas prévu comme ça préparez la
turquie n'a pas du tout été prévu comme
ça justement c'est contre nature et des
cyclos mina l'empoli la pilule parce que
j'ai un moment et infirmières elles chez
un pédiatre et c'est inimaginable nombre
d'enfants qui naissent justement déformé
par les conséquences de la piscine les
enfants naissent souvent aux normes ou
pas je pense qu'il est beaucoup mieux
d'avoir des pilules qui aidait les
filles reviennent indique non vers des
quantités d'avoir eut annoncé beaucoup
mieux bien sûr c'est le progrès et puis
non seulement pour les jeunes mais bien
pour les gens mariés y en a que ça
intéresse a drôlement aussi la débauche
pourquoi la débauche on entraîne la
débauche pourquoi parce qu'il ya des
hippies tout ça mais ça c'est vous savez
de tout temps il ya eu des couilles du
temps des blousons noirs et du temps
durs est automatiquement pétrole tandis
qu'ils puis le temps de tout autre chose
pourquoi être à la débauche si vous avez
des parents qui élèvent leurs enfants
correctement et je pense qu'elle a
beaucoup dans ce cas-là tout de même
faut le donner la liberté à la jeunesse
mme bien entendu jusqu'à un certain
point
il revient toujours au même une fille
qui prend moyens de contraception est
avec un garçon donc si tu avais avec un
autre ensuite c'est vrai avec un autre
quand je connais un garçon une heure
après je suis pas dans son lit
tout simplement je tenais beaucoup de
gamine de deux saisons qui attendent
même pas une heure les toute façon sur
la terre il ya que 2 et pour guy pour
l'amour c'est l'homme et le singe
et continuellement pour moi un enfant
c'est quelque chose que je dois vouloir
que je dois désiré championne enfants
comme ça par hasard c'est moche mais
vouloir un enfant de nantes que j'aime
c'est quelque chose de merveilleux et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut la pilule
[Musique]